don't get tonight I kind of wanted to
talk about when it's appropriate to
resign or not and the way that this kind
of happened I'll just give a little back
story for how tonight's lecture evolved
into what I hope it's gonna be and we're
gonna do something a little more
experimental I like to mix things up and
try new things in this class so we'll
try something a little different tonight
during the Friday action quads this week
there's a player who comes to the club
he's a regular now he probably does want
me to mention his name but he's he's
rated just under a thousand he can often
play you know like he's twice his rating
for the whole game and then at the very
end he just blender something from a
completely winning position and he's
just blown so many winning positions
that that keeps his rating down below
1000 when really I mean I keep telling
them you know you should be a 1600
player if you could just win these
positions that you're just completely
winning and I mean you know just be
totally winning he'll just be up like
two Queens and somehow still lose it
doesn't make any sense because he played
the game so well and something that I've
done in the past with my private
students especially the ones that are
you know twelve to sixteen hundred rated
or whatever I give them positions where
they're clearly better and it's a good
exercise because you can look at it from
different perspectives like if it's sort
of a Jewish player you know rated like a
thousand I might give them okay we both
have two ropes but you have the only
open file and just for fun let's give
you a night or something and so can you
win this position so I defend a lot of
these really bad positions and I've
noticed that okay I just get trying to
get active yet counter play so we're
going to sort of discuss the psychology
of you know being winning in the game
versus a player that's losing during the
game so we're going to explore that that
theme a little bit and so sort of one of
the things I wanted to talk about is is
when when it when not to resign I'll
talk a little bit more about it but
let's just get this position on the
board this was a game that was played in
the Wednesday nights
it was a game between mr. Martin he and
Zubin chandran so we'll be looking at
Zubin won this game he had the black
pieces and he was playing at Martin who
the internet knows is that salty
character that played on the Apple is
funny with Mike comer and we won't talk
too much about the opening we're just
gonna get to the the very last position
in the game they transposed to a French
it could have been a classical so e5
here would be a normal move but he
decided transpose into the exchange
variation and we're not gonna worry so
much about any of these opening moves
it's just the final position that we're
gonna care about here see it is kind of
whatever okay he took the night which is
not a great deal why would you give it a
night away
a bishop away from it for a night for no
real reason and you guys can probably
see it here not you guys at home but a
bar did the annotations for this game so
you guys get the inside scoop here if
you can read them on the side
c5 this was a really good move so now I
mean Black is better in this position
and he got to this position okay and
then some some funny stuff happens some
era game Roque one doesn't make any
sense to me
that's not and here I think white cloud
he had a little tactic so okay so he
miscalculated and he took this pawn and
he must be thinking all right you take
my knight and I take here and I yeah I
would have fun but obviously black
doesn't have to do that he can either
just take this Knight directly or you
can play what he played in the game and
now black is winning okay
okay so a tactical blunder and here
black decided to take back with the rook
and in this position white resigned okay
you're down to piece and okay okay it
would have also just been better to have
taken with a pawn just with the idea of
it now you're protecting this rank and
you're not allowing any counter play so
this is the position I want to talk
about and white resigned but this is the
challenge that I'm gonna do for the
class tonight I'm gonna take the white
side and I'm gonna try to show the the
potential to get activity in this
position that white possibly has okay
black here a piece up so that's perfect
and I'll make my first move now I'll
just all right I'm gonna take this pawn
and I'm gonna get a lot of activity
along this rank now if you are playing
in the Sinquefield Cup and this is the
position on the board okay you should
probably resign because you're playing
the world's elite but if you're playing
in the Knights tournament or you know
and if you're watching this video you
probably play amateur tournaments
probably not a professional chess player
though I think some good people actually
watch me I'm always surprised but okay
actually you know if you're just a
normal club player you probably
shouldn't resign here and so something
kind of happens when the game
psychologically changes a little bit
once somebody is clearly winning in this
position so let me just make my move on
the board and so you kind of want to
think how how is white thinking in this
position what is the what's going on in
his mind well as soon as you're you're
losing you no longer have anything to
lose you know and nothing else matters
okay I mean oh great I got double pawns
doesn't matter what all I care about now
is white is somehow I have to get
activity I have to drum up an attack I
have to somehow get some massive counter
play going in this position and okay and
as black you're kind of thinking yard I
just need to consolidate I need to
construct a position where I just
neutralize all of White's pressure and
then I should be able to win because I'm
up a piece but it's not always that easy
so I would never have resigned if I were
playing in the Knights tournament in
this position and just because I've been
playing around with this for a couple
days now so hopefully I can play well as
as white we're gonna see this kind of an
experiment taking a big risk play in the
class what but people hope people like
when people fail on the internet so this
could be
maybe I'll just messed up but we have a
really good editor out there it's
looking very good today you know dress
really well tonight I like it it's
important you know if you don't make
them happy than you so I'm going to go
ahead I'll give you I'll give you guys a
minute here so at home if you want to
plan as black and it's hopefully a
little more more dangerous for black
than it looks at first blush then go
ahead and pause your video I'm gonna
give the class here a minute or two and
then we'll talk a little bit more about
this position and okay if you haven't
also done so - again we we always want
to be thinking sort of prophylactically
what our opponents are thinking it is
sort of very important to think okay if
I were white you know how would I be
getting any activity in this type of
position so I don't want to give away
too much because you know hopefully I
can show off a few tricks in this
position for the audience why is it sup
and then you look up in alright hi there
what are you what do you think in this
position come here
you wanna see with me again yeah mommy
Jonna come sit with me
Joe I said with me go yeah yeah that's
mommy yeah gonna sit with me
all right good you can help me out you
can help me out a little bit all right
okay so does anybody here I'll good we
got some firepower coming in the room
now
can you keep that door shut and then
okay
I got my I got my helper so it's it's
two on four so you won't have a move
they would like to suggest as black here
94 that's your suggestion okay so then
it goes into e4 and add two ideas here I
want to try this move queen g4 okay
making very obvious very obvious threat
rook to c7
okay okay
where you want to go h8 ok big mistake
that's my neither can I so it's fair
match
alright we'll see you all right yep you
came in blundered peace he's out that's
how it works we shut the story ok but I
mean this is this is probably fine so in
this position I think instead you have
to go here and okay I mean at minimum I
okay I'm starting to get some sort of
activity here at least I'm getting
something that's definitely not enough I
don't think but this is just sort of how
I have to play this as white and
hopefully all these pawns will sort of
confuse you and okay so in this move but
uh you know so this probably shouldn't
be enough for white but I'm always
trying to create as many problems as
possible which is what I have to do
because I'm I'm losing here so I don't
feel like I completely refuted this move
but
okay because I mean because you are you
are winning just does anybody else have
any other ideas or do you want to talk
about that as as black so it does yeah
you there's this urge to you know okay
just go get them and we can overwhelm
him but the thing of this position is my
pieces are really active so I'm actually
gonna be creating threats and I do have
the possibility of mating you or at
least getting a really strong attack
against your king
mostly because I have a very very active
piece so even though I have less pieces
what I need to do is make them more
active than your pieces so that even
though I have less they're doing more
and causing you more problems so I want
you to have to like ball up all your
pieces and defend and okay and
eventually to and I am focused on the
positives
I do hope one day that I can make
something of my pawns here so I mean I'm
hoping I catch a can get a passer okay
that might cause you some problems so
you know trying to I'm just trying to
focus on the good cuz if you just you
know think about the bad in the position
might just fall and you resign but
hopefully by the end of the night I can
you know I'll cause some problems and
show that this position is not
altogether so easy to just you know you
just win because you're up a piece I
think there's some a lot of practical
problems that we might be able to cause
here so we got a lot of new faces so
I'll go ahead and we'll we'll start back
at this position so my last move is rook
takes b7 and so I'm playing as the white
pieces here you guys have black your
piece up and the challenges can you can
you win we have some some decent players
know so I think I think we'll see 94 is
a good move as we've seen is there any
other okay
excellent glad you asked yeah whatever
right there very you know tempting move
you know just take the pond I'll just
keep taking yourself and we're gonna see
what the problem is so this is a big
square that I'm trying to make use of
e6000 seventh-ranked so okay I'll play
this move h4 and I'll ask you where are
you gonna go so now you have to make a
decision with your knight
wherever you go I'm going to bring my
queen somewhere very active
94 right yeah seems very logical so I
again this is where I'm trying to go so
f3 yeah and I know F there is a lot
better than it was in the other version
that we were looking at because you know
this seems seems still ok for black
doesn't it now d6 II mean yeah so this
so here's the problem right so now I am
gonna get a lot of activity here come
and when you move what move do I have
well you guys got to tell me I don't
know but I have a trip d7 so I'm at
least getting material back here so this
is a big success for me I mean so and
we've get this position you don't resign
this white you know so that is my goal
and so you can kind of see I have these
ideas you know I'm gonna that somehow
I'm gonna attack your Knight my Queens
you know coming in here okay also I have
other ideas you know somehow I'm gonna
get my queen just some really really
active square I'm gonna cause you a lot
of lot of problems here but okay we'll
go back so don't taking the pawn this
Brooksie seven okay this is a mistake
now the last person that made this
mistake just left the room they're alive
I've wondered my feet in them yes it's
true we here were you here when the yeah
it's a slightly different position but
it's the same same blender all right I
take it so this is the point yeah so you
can't take the rook see just you
blundered arrested yeah okay but stay
here don't go please please you're the
highest rated player in the room Zippo
cup so that is right so it does
highlight there's there is a lot of
danger here based on okay you've played
this move f6 which is already sort of a
weakening move I'm trying to you know
focus on my potential here yeah yeah the
f6 was alright when it was played but
you know I it does give me some some
chances now yeah you're up tonight
you're gonna win alright so I took on b7
your turn but I'm glad you said that
because I was hoping somebody would say
that yeah
and hopefully when we do this enough
you'll start to see all of my ideas and
then you'll you'll be able to defend it
and hopefully the COS is able to win
this position tonight yeah do you want
it you wanna try it
sure go for it knight of seven if I put
this over here
okay so this is you know starting to go
my way a little bit now you know you
imagine it before now my queen and my
rope they're both awesome pieces your
Knights pinned your Queens only job is
to defend the knife so okay I take this
and I'm gonna take your deep on and then
there's there's one trick that you have
because I've already looked at this
position in my prep but there's a chance
I can fall for a tactical mistake
so let me blunder cuz that's fun alright
if you take here here here some some
some move I don't know let me just make
some random yeah so there's this idea -
so it's checked and you pick up the rope
so I can plunder - you know it's and
it's funny - that the White Queen like
you're not getting back on the back rank
you know so it's like darn I don't get
to like do funny back rank stuff okay so
there's that trick in the position but
really after here I'll just play a move
like g3 or something so that if you
check me I just step up and I'm you know
you're a little tied down and I got to
pass pawns you know I'm start pushing my
upon then if 7 is is probably not the
best move but it's you know that's what
you're kind of it's like I should be so
easy to defend yeah I just bring my
pieces back it's really not that easy
you want to play Rick see it sure yeah
sure
sure you want me to take on 87 sure we
nee eight alright well I don't want to
simplify an electric okay no train
okay and then yeah you're seeing my
potential I'm gonna have to keep you
away before I do that but you thought
I'd play for fine I'll play it for if
that's what you that's what you worried
about I'm sure that seems fine welcome
back all right they haven't beaten me
yet so I'm doing okay she keeps dropping
off and then she just leaves all right
go find her be safe out there okay now
you want to play 94 is you breaking the
connection of my pieces here okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna try to be tricky okay
makes sense and that's yes so that's
that's true you're trying to just
simplify so I have to really do my best
to avoid trains I got to keep all the
pieces on the board and I have to keep
making threats so I'm always I'm always
just gonna be looking for ways to make
some big threats here and okay so I
don't feel like this was a real success
I feel like you're just kind of I need
to say it's lazy play but it's it's sort
of his lazy play um okay so I just took
time to be something so you really do
need a plan to stop me from doing all of
my my tricks here it's not easy
rook c6 an excellent move this is the
best move oh yeah okay so this I've been
looking at a lot so this is the main
line the computer line and you know a
computer will say you know you're like
yeah plus two or something you know it's
like you're up two points okay so it's I
have a some small compensation for the
piece that you have I mean I got some
extra pawn this is new that's that's
what I got going for me but I mean it
shouldn't be enough um and there's a
bunch of tricky tries here I think but
first of all I'm gonna I'm not gonna
start out with the good stuff
all right I'm not we're gonna start out
strong we're just gonna I'm just gonna
illustrate some points I'm not gonna do
anything I'm just gonna take this okay
I'll come back play I'll play better
when you guys play better
okay this is interesting look so I do I
do have to be careful I can't let this
happen
so I'm actually it's um some danger okay
so I'm gonna not let you do that by
putting yeah I'll make my own moves I've
like Queen B 5 um okay so now you can't
check me on the first rank and then play
Europe's I've stopped that Sam saw your
idea stop hooray for me but now
okay haven't you guys like to continue
now I'm in this I guess just for the
sake of time let me try to play the
hardest move now I don't objectively
think it's the best move but I think
okay either 8 or even f4 here it's very
very tricky I have a really sneaky idea
my idea is if you go here
okay here
and this is incredibly dangerous and in
fact there's only one mode for black
otherwise you lose this is my this is my
really really tricky idea so this is a
nice challenge and I hope you I'm going
to pause your video here because this is
can you find the move there's only one
move here and that's sort of the way
that I want to play as white this
variation is not you know the most
objectively best way to play if you're
an engine you know you put on the engine
it's like oh you just lost some smidge
of an advantage is white how could you
even consider f4 well I'm playing humans
and I want to cause as many practical
problems and you can take some risks and
it's not that much of a risk to play
this way I mean okay there's always the
risk that he's gonna defend properly and
win the game but by making it so that
you have to find only moves in order to
survive there's the real possibility
that even if I'm playing a decently
strong player you know they might not
play right here and I think if you look
at it you'll notice that there's some
some problems to solve here as black so
this is a big issue so if you know you
just casually go here I mean I take care
check I'm on your rook your knight you
know everything's falling apart see you
you have to be really careful we can
make this blender again because that's
fun that this one doesn't get old so you
do have to be careful there's a lot of a
lot of possibility to go wrong and it's
exactly how you want to play this when
you're down the piece
okay so 96 is a move that you kind of
want to play unfortunately you've
blocked the connection between the Queen
and your deep on I'll take care check on
your King I'm on your rook so you know
okay if you move somewhere okay this is
not right okay
no but that's definitely you know that's
one of the defensive moves you want to
take into account but it doesn't work
you know these this idea of blocking
with this or blocking with this or
blocking with this it's really difficult
to play when Wayne has so much activity
that's sort of the point and okay
another blunder we can make is here okay
that's a nice way to block but while
we're here
whichever one I haven't decided I'd have
to think about it for I'd have to think
about it for more time and we're running
low on time yes so how are you gonna
deal with this threat on f7 so you need
to make sure and think about think about
my turn okay let's give your opponent
the turn your opponent is me so okay I'm
gonna play here so your king is gonna go
here and my third is obviously on g7 so
you can make it such that when my queen
lands on f7 you have time to protect
your Jeep on you can't right now because
you'd be in check if I play Queen f7
it's check so the only move and
hopefully I've given it away King h8 so
this is the only move okay it's not the
end of your trouble though let me see
don't remember do I take on a seven or
dive like penis
oh no okay no no I'll take care I got an
idea okay because sometimes what I want
to do is I want to go here and threaten
me but I also have this other trick that
I can use sometimes in this position I
can go here to threaten yeah we're game
so I got some really sneaky ideas you
know I'm trying to stay ahead of the
class but this is winning this is
winning for black so okay so you can go
to g8 and this is kind of the move that
I'm hoping to see because of your and
your queen it's not better I'm g8 and I
didn't have to threaten anything to
force you to do it so all right I'm just
gonna wait and even my waiting moves are
strong they're May I'm putting my pawns
so and four or five moves from now you
did it that might be a very serious
issue I suspect that this is fine for
you though you want
when I play here it seems fine King h2 I
could push my palm hours this dear
children is the urged tacky once
what's that
it's tempting to attack a trip once it's
tempting but uh okay but I see your you
might come down and check with me so
I'll just get out of the way now you
know sorry my rook is still just super
monster Queens doing a good job yeah big
deal big deal you got an extra night
okay
yeah so you just go there anyway okay I
know this rook h1 okay you haven't you
have a threat okay you have a threat is
that your thread yeah you are
why stop it
and this lit was too good it's too good
he's too good if I go here yeah that
didn't change anything goes a joke
that wasn't funny okay
all right I got
nor catch one night just like him dude
oh that's my idea they won't wanna play
whoopsy one we're running out of time so
all right thank you
let's see if I can I don't I rewrite
their isn't you just not taking my
condom do I have to be kind of be kind
of careful okay I mean I have to go
you know attempted to go here know if I
take on like defense or something
hey blaze do you go to mr. Andrews class
did you go over how the Knights move you
gonna sit down and watch all right
you're gonna repeat yeah to threaten
maybe I'll fall for it maybe I'll go
somewhere fine okay
are you gonna go simplify here okay yeah
I think you should you're in trick
Queens yeah okay yeah don't get back
remanded but these things can be avoided
kingi eight okay you don't want to get
me in on the background I don't want you
to take my Jeep on you had a chance you
had a chance to take it don't know why
you didn't take it but do I don't you
want to take it
I'll do anything to speed along you guys
beating me I mean I assume you're still
winning but
I don't I don't really understand we
didn't technically I ponder okay you
want it you want taking the sign for the
audience
okay edge to kind of past
and get behind the a farm okay you're
gonna go for my pond
how dare you
family show there's school in giad okay
he doesn't like to get made it very
understandable very
now you want to get by the Oh suck my
thumb
day five
okay so this seems reasonable
I wrote later you want to play 95 don't
take me okay
Sylla incredibly easy yeah
the Kings on da
qf 87
right
wait
okay
you know least try to make it difficult
do you want to go this way
now you're gonna go to d6
okay so okay so you go here yes
just take enough
just hang on a five
okay you know it's it's bleak but I've
won worse positions so and that is sort
of the thing too that that happens and
okay so as embarrassing as it is I've
been playing people five six hundred
points already to me and I've been
losing before but it doesn't matter so I
do miss I was showing I should somebody
was this game the other day and it was
so I was playing somebody I guess he was
like fourteen or fifteen hundred
whatever he was I was down a road none
of my pieces were developed King wide
open I always knew it would so he was
just crushing me it was like the
computers monstrous numbers but it
didn't matter because I found a way I
just went alone meant ricktum and you
know it was just sort of the same thing
I just tried to get really active pieces
I try to cause as many problems as
possible and I you know I just I found
some tactics that just worked out and so
I was able to do it and it's been on the
other side too you know I'm playing very
strong players there are 500 points
higher than me crushing them and then
the same thing happens you know they
just keep finding ways and the higher
are rated you are the more you are in a
losing position the more capable you are
of causing problems and making it
difficult to always find the right moves
for your opponent so that's something
you'll notice how you read players just
do really well you know so I mean it's
it's fine okay good you're you're
beating a grandmaster but then to win
from that winning position is actually
still quite a feat you know it's okay
just because you're you're beating a
grandmaster doesn't mean you're gonna
win and it's true whatever level you are
if you're 700 and you're playing at 1100
you know it's just it's great you know
you're winning but it just to actually
win you actually have to play very
accurately it's a difficult art just
playing from behind and still still
winning so even when you're ahead you
still have to win it's not easy but uh
okay for time we'll have to end it here
I think that pretty well does it I'll
give you I'll give you guys this one I
think it's time for me to resign I would
you know I would never resign here I
just keep fighting but that's sort of
the the idea I won't worry too much
about all its maybe it's impolite to
keep playing or
you know if you're at the the elite
level you know okay you should have
resigned to your a long time ago but if
you're not playing in the Sinquefield
cup you know you're playing at the local
tournament you're playing in the nights
and the Friday action quads you don't
want to resign you want to keep fighting
here and find ways to pose as many
problems to your opponent as possible
make it very difficult for him to win
and at home let me know if you like this
format this is something you want to do
again the lecturer versus the audience
we could find you know we could do this
again at some other sort of format some
other game or some other position I just
wanted to let's just go back really
quick here all the way back to the very
first position we'll just go back to
this position on the board and so again
it's it seems so easy you know you're a
piece up everything you're just cruising
but you know the surprising ability of
white to find ways to enter into this
position actually post lots and lots of
problems so you did have to think about
your opponent's play and consolidate in
a very unusual way so if you liked it go
ahead
yeah hit like hit share subscribe tell
everybody in the world
you